oh
we made it back to the house and we have
the key
chat we have
the key all right guys this is it man
this is it i've been really curious to
know what happens
when you do this right here
people of the internet retro recontour
here and welcome back to
return most unfortunately there are a
couple of bugs that are causing people
to lose
entire saves now fortunately for me i
didn't completely lose that save however
i did lose the run that i was currently
on
i'd only died one time as of the end of
last time's recording however in today's
video
we're gonna change that because we die a
lot that being said we also
finally get to see what's inside the
house
let me know what you guys think about
returnal so far i'd love to hear from
you down in the comments below and if
you like these videos be sure to give it
a thumbs up
as always thank you all so much for
watching enjoy the video
the red doors require a key
at least the first time that you go
through
but yeah so watch let's see if this this
door works now so when i first started
the game tonight
that first door wouldn't even open the
environment
wasn't like this before no it was not
like this
it's completely different now all right
get rid of that guy
oh no
i hate it when it drops me down like
that
it's a bug i know dude they they issued
an update
and a lot of people completely lost
saves
so i'm wondering if i should like if it
keeps happening do i need to
you know what maybe i need to reinstall
the game
i might have to completely reinstall the
game
whoa it took me back up nice
now if i take this one
is that gonna take me back down okay
perfect yeah
this is a new area
yeah i know how to take on you now
silphium nice
all right so here we go with another
another side area
let's see what's happening
those little yellow things i'm
collecting are called oblets
which you can use to upgrade certain
things
so let's see how many we have right now
actually 87 obelets
zero keys three ether at the moment
i need to find that house again because
the house the house key that i have
actually did carry over
when i first started playing i came up
on this mysterious house
now i did in my first playthrough
encounter an area
just like this but hold on a second this
is like
oh dude this is like another metroid
thing here
clearly i can't reach that based on my
current abilities
maybe there's something i'm going to be
able to get later that will help me to
get across that gap
all right we'll be back we'll be back
here i can tell
yeah what they said intense aim was if
you installed like
there was an update they pushed out that
had a problem they didn't really say
what the problem was
oh wow that dude was hiding back there
but if you downloaded that update then
they said you'll need to reinstall your
game
well i had my game left in a uh
save whatever you call it on ps5 like
the save and resume
mode and so i was hoping it wouldn't
auto update because i was in
you know had that game in rest mode but
apparently it did anyway
so when i hopped on tonight though i
hadn't turned on my ps5
since i played this last which was
whenever it came out thursday or
something
no translocators active
so i don't know if it installed that
second update the bad one or not
or if i just got the good update
but i did do it i did check for update
when we started playing and it did not
need
an update said i was running the latest
version
yeah i i knew i knew there was gonna be
something in here
oh my goodness there's a lot in this
area man
yeah we need a better uh oh boy
i'm waiting for my all fire to come back
dude
there we go take out a couple right
there
wow this room was loaded with enemies
i actually think this is the most
enemies i've seen in one room so far
there we go enhanced vision let's go
i hear another one still there he is
yeah i don't want to do the alt fire
that was intense that was intense
all right let's reset let's reset
do i still hear another one
yeah i i that's the thing in ten same i
don't know i don't know if it
i i mean as far as i know i didn't get
the bad update because i didn't even
turn on my ps5 but it very well could
have like auto updated and
oh cool
small silphium gives me some health
so my main objective right now locate
the white shadow broadcast and i
need to search for the anathema key
oh and we've got two little side areas
to explore right here
also a container but i think we've
already opened that container
oh no it's the container up there isn't
it yeah we can't get up there yet
so yeah there's definitely an item that
we're gonna get later on that i
i guarantee will somehow allow me to get
up to those areas
did you guys hear that
whoa whoa
i don't like the looks of this thing
over here
okay so yeah this is one of those little
translocators so now i could use this
one to warp
to that spot right there but you know
that's
okay so that's i'm at t1 that's t2
no i'm at t2 that's t1 all right
i'm afraid reconstructor
a xenotech accurate reconstruction
of complex entities per
environment not enough ether i only have
three and i need
six so ether seems pretty important and
also pretty hard to come by
the three that i have i'm almost
positive carried over from last time
because i have not picked up any ether
this go round
all right at least that door opened
okay let's check in the other side area
it's gonna be the one over here
oh am i able to reach this though
i don't think so i think it's behind
there isn't it no
it's up here there we go
i thought i heard something right here
oh nice
damaged fabricator a damaged xenotech
device fabricates a random item in
exchange
for an increasing amount of omelets ooh
i only have
153 this would take nearly half of them
i don't know if i want to waste them on
something that i don't even know
i don't even know what it's going to
give me dude
let me read it one more time here
fabricates a random item in exchange
yeah i'm not gonna risk that
please open okay good
all right and now we're ready to
go to the left because we can't reach
that other area right now
oh you know there's gonna be something
big in here
you can just it just just has that look
broken calibrator
look at that man gosh this game is just
gorgeous
full of mystery like i just find myself
wanting to explore
every little inch of like i don't even
know if i can drop down there or not but
i want to go
and see what's down there
is that gonna get him oh no
oh boy
the aiming is really interesting because
not only am i focused on aiming i'm also
trying to
keep an eye on the bullets so i know
when i'm when i need to get ready to
reload oh okay this is
one of the parasites so the parasites
they offer something that helps you
and then they also have something that
will hurt you so if i pick this one up
it will increase my protection by 15
but i will suffer damage when picking up
items i don't think that's worth it
i mean i guess ideally when you're
picking up items
you are you've already cleared the area
but what if i like quickly need to grab
some health or something in it
and it hurts me
let's take a look here uh not yet not
yet let's go see what's down here
there was definitely something else over
oh yeah look at this man
nice a trophy key
i don't know guys i don't know maybe
i'll find a better parasite
i don't like the idea of taking damage
just for picking up items though
that does not sound very fun
a container for presumably valuable
items
safe to open oh let's go
new weapon i can swap my sidearm which
is not that great
for this spit mall blaster
yeah it's rated higher so see what it's
like
oh it's like shotgun shotgun slug style
right there
all right now let's see what the
alt-fire is
it's kind of the same thing maybe a
little bit more of a focused
translocator so this is number three
all right nice oh there's a container
over there that i didn't
open see that one that has the circle
filled in
see guys this is why i love their the
style of this map here
i love that it shows me everything that
i'm missing
what is this oh that's just the other
gun
uh is there anything else oh yeah we can
keep going
deeper deeper deeper
oh
oh geez adrenaline reset
now this guy right here
oh man i'm about to die right here
you have to use melee on him first
come on get up here
oh i'm about dead i'm about dead
why am i not shooting man i need to be
shooting the entire time
oh that was terrible terrible terrible
terrible
electrical ability on these guys
oh man i'm almost dead almost dead okay
okay regroup regroup regroup
okay do we go for kills or do we go for
life
area in lockdown no they're trying to
keep me here man
i'm not even gonna worry about reloading
right now
yeah not even gonna bother trying to
because i know i'm just gonna i see help
jump over him no i fell
no
all upcoming weapons approved we gotta
get out of this so dude
no no no no
no oh
that run was going so much better
dude this area is crazy do it i
oh gosh i thought i heard something
oh no it's another one of these things
wait a second
come on it's got to be something big
reclaimer a xenotech device for
recycling materials
output unknown
warning interaction can damage integrity
so like what the heck what's the point
of using this thing
fills two slots toward max integrity but
it infected with malignancy
we got to read this again like wait what
is
a xenotech device for recycling
materials output unknown i mean
you know we gotta fig we gotta see what
it does
i'm not gonna like this dude i'm not
gonna like this
no
what the heck what did i just do
oh great my health is my health is no
artifact
please don't kill me fractal nail
grants plus 10 weapon damage while you
have a malfunction
um well i'm kind of worried about the
damage
to my suit right now
it feels two slots toward max integrity
oh no no no
no why did that do so much damage to me
why did it do so much damage
you know i'm gonna get attacked right
freaking now
i don't like this i don't like this
gosh a door no
no
tell me that's it oh there's another one
right there you can see him dude
you can see him look at that look at
that
and back there
oh yeah i see you see you too
oh i love that enhanced vision it shows
me like where they're
yep if we just kind of keep our distance
right here
oh there's health there's health
oh i see you dude
imagine if the last one killed me
imagine
oh wow gee thanks for the like
for the tiny drop of health
you just bestowed upon me
oh man we're trying chat we're trying
get away i see health i must go for it
okay let's regroup here let's regroup
all right got him
okay that one we have to get close in
melee
all right get rid of you yeah pretty
i was pretty sure we couldn't
oh man oh man
no no no no
no no not like this
journal level five man
all right let's go in
boom gotcha see that was a much lower
boom
guys that was a much lower boom
hopefully no ears were damaged on that
one
all right is that it is that it
dude we have got to find the upgrade
that
jesus scares me every time
it scares me every time
oh no we gotta hurry about to run out
like there's nothing down here to hurt
you at least
so far there hasn't been but just like
the immediate caving in
oh man
okay what i was trying oh that is
oh oh are those just leaves
i think they're just leaves
oh can't reach it oh what's this
translocation sphere what
transports you to an unknown location
i'm going to keep that because i mean i
could see how that could be useful if
you get into a spot where
you just need like a quick exit and you
don't really care
where you go you're just like get me out
of here please
then i could see how that would be
useful
so i'm gonna i'm gonna hang on to that
one
we're still not great on health oh
we made it back to the house
and we have the key chat we have
the key
oh man please nothing stop me before
we get oh oh
i heard something oh what are those
nice okay that's t4 right by the house
all right guys this is it man this is it
i've been really curious to know what
happens
when you do this right here
oh my gosh we're first person exactly
but impossible i don't like where this
is going dude
oh wait
what the heck
i logged my first missions in this
binder
because this is stored in the mother
ships archives
can i go in here no
somebody's gotta drop in and think i'm
playing resident evil or something
okay that's not creepy at all just a
complete black
pit inside a house
was taken after you left wait what
i was taken after you left
oh my word
hello what is this
game dude what is this game
oh no okay wait wait wait wait which way
do we go guys
do we go upstairs or do we go over here
there's there's footsteps upstairs
but then like this just appeared
i feel like we need to go upstairs i
feel like we gotta investigate this
we gotta this is the house from pt
right who's there
oh my gosh dude what the heck man what
the heck is this game
this is not what i signed up for
what such strange
oh i hear i hear like a beast man
i hear a beast lurking yeah where that
window is i hear him
is this like stranger things or
something it's gonna be the dude with
the big eye
oh no don't look away guys
oh what the heck dude she's in outer
space
oh no she's losing it
i'm actually really curious to see like
where this story goes man
like what actually is happening with her
trophy earned welcome home no i wanted
to see what was down that other hall
darn it i knew i knew i would mess up
if we oh man i wonder if you can go back
in am i supposed to remember this
new item unlocked oh what new item do we
get
astronaut figurine personal item it will
not let you go
oh my gosh is that actually an artifact
wait is it going in my
it is it doesn't say what it does though
uh the fractal nail is the 10 weapon
damage while you have a malfunction
but neither of those are in the
permanent equipment
i want to try to go back in man oh you
can't
darn it kojimask
the house from pt see now i wish i would
have went down that hall first because
hopefully we didn't miss anything maybe
it just like tells you to turn around or
something
dude yes
this is like an upgrade room
okay if you didn't see the first stream
then you haven't seen
a room like this yet so
the fabricator we should obviously we
definitely need to use the fabricator
because it'll get rid of that
malfunction we just got to decide which
one we
we want here
okay so translocation sphere we already
have that large silvium vial repairs a
major amount of integrity
dude i think i think i need to do that
one for sure
and then use it right away but let's see
what else we got
blade balancer
enables a more powerful melee attack now
that's just an
artifact i don't think artifacts carry
over
execution blast melee kills generate
energy blasts
recharging overload successful overloads
reduce okay we already had that one
i don't know what the middle is for like
i think we definitely need to do the
we clearly need health and then i think
i might do this one
a more powerful melee
let's do this one right here and then
we're just going to immediately use it
to restore health
malfunction removed nice okay wait so
it's already equipped i just need to hit
l1
nice okay that's big time man
that's big time and then we can just
pick this back up
i'm trying to think i think i'm going to
do this one too that one's gone
yeah let's do this one too we've got 379
this is this costs 250.
now we might have to start deciding
which
artifacts we want because i think you
have a limit
let's see where do they show up oh you
can have a bunch of artifacts
so let's see what is that 5 10 15
15 artifacts all right
i don't need to okay i think i'm about
out of oblites now what's this one do
here
no i wish i would have seen this one
first
max integrity by 25
that's okay we just need 325 we got 129
so
almost 200 more
dude i really wish we would hit a point
where we like have some sort of
save stay to reach a new area or
something
oh another one of these
all right that's t5 all right let's just
see if we can make it to the objective
excuse me excuse me
dude this thing is so much more powerful
wait why is he not done oh he's getting
healed
this thing's healing him
locked down lifted okay
now it's just these regular guys but a
lot of them
a lot of them first i was like my
goodness man
they have upped their health for this
area
oh no not again not again
then i was like wait a second uh this is
a tropium key
let's go all right we're
dude this is a really solid run now
we've got it we've got a key
all the malignancies are removed we've
got some solid upgrades
we got to see what was in the house
finally and oh my goodness we got
another one of these guys
wait what i want to hit no hit him
melee again melee again look at that
three melee attacks
get him out of the picture
i'm gonna stick with the weapon i have
serving me well dude serving me well
all upcoming weapons improved
so that's what proficiency does it
improves the quality of the items
that you come into contact with in the
future
whoops i hear another one still though
broken calibrator
another etropian key
this room had two keys in it let's go
and then we're gonna we're gonna need to
warp all the way back here because
wasn't that one of the areas that we
couldn't get to
and there's a fabricator behind it okay
there was a red door somewhere you guys
i don't remember where but there was
definitely a red door somewhere
i think we should just keep pressing on
though right now i want to get to this
objective man i want to see
what is at the end of this
whoa what is this it's got a star above
the door
yikes
no i'm not going in there yet dude
that's a boss room man you know
you know it's got to be a boss room
oh i didn't think there was a way to get
down in here
where are you at show yourself
did i get him
nope what what what
okay water bad
i remember that now first night i played
i remember that
knocked off quite a bit of help too
actually
all right i definitely need to check out
what's down there but
if i okay i go down here
an ether yes dude those things are so
hard to find
got more health over here so we can go
ahead and
get our health back
oh no that was just a a little health
upgrade node
don't fall in the water
and then we gotta see what's in that
area man with the star above it
now we do have a key for this
we do have a key for this
i'll take it but like i'm not thrilled
with that artifact
we've had that one before the oblates
last three seconds longer whoopee
oh how did i miss that up there
all right we got a couple ways we can go
yet again
um i'm gonna go here to this one first
and then we've we've gotta i mean we've
gotta check out what's behind the star
door right
does it not say on the map like what's
containment gate okay it does tell us
all right in that case let's go back
let's go back and see
i mean if it's a boss fight it's a boss
fight so be it
so be it i'm gonna have to wrap up the
stream soon anyway
oh yeah here we go dude
dude that is so incredible
okay everyone's gonna need melee
destroyed let's go
more hostiles incoming
a little tree guys
got him
all right we got plenty of health
nice nice
let's go dude let's go
what is this room
what is this room chat
no what is this thing freaking metroid
no
okay okay okay okay calm down calm down
come on he's almost dead he's almost
dead he's almost dead he's almost dead
oh geez jeez
i thought there were more yes all these
omelets please
now this one right here would be a level
two weapon modified sidearm
like what
i don't know man i don't know if that's
better than the one i got
all that work
i really don't know if it's better than
the one i have
shield file creates a shield against the
next hit
yes please that sounds really helpful
especially right now with my health
being at what it is i mean
dude
let me see this one more time i mean
that that would probably be pretty sick
but this shock stream is just incredible
blast oh now that's a level four
it has one bonus damage one increase in
the effective range
two increases on the stagger power
i might have to finally say bye to the
shock stream guys
just because it's i wonder if it's that
much more powerful though
what is this dude another ether
unknown artifact potentially beneficial
phantom limb eliminating hostiles has a
chance to repair integrity
that is awesome right there so you can
you actually have a chance to get some
health back
just by taking out enemies dude that is
going to be super
super helpful i mean how many times have
we been running through these areas
having to be very very cautious
just because of our health being so low
all right well i gotta say this room was
well worth it
this room was well worth it now we
haven't
opened up that one yet so we need to
just head on back over there
go through this door
keep going this way
hope that nothing new attacks us
and i mean that's the area we want to
head over there
oh yeah the locked door
oh wait wait wait is this a new this is
a new area
i thought this was the same spot i
already been
maybe it is maybe it is
let's go another one all right
health is in a great spot right now
now if i hop into these little tentacles
over here
oh my goodness they come after me now
all right that's new
that's new
i mean they always attack you but i'm
pretty sure they don't usually attack
that close
all right now we do have one more key
one more key to use there we go
are you serious i used it in an area
where i can't even reach the next spot
dude those take a long time to
destroy with this slug shot
i don't think he can reach it up there
dude where am i
you guys were talking about being lost
earlier like i'm officially no
no no no no no
and of course i've got this slug shot
thing man which just does not
i'm dead i'm dead dude i'm dead right
here
no see it takes away damage but it
should bring me back
no i just fell again i can't fall again
guys we gotta
no
no no wait wait wait wait why am i still
alive
why am i still alive second chance
returned by the astronaut figurine
oh my goodness chat the astronaut
figurine
coming in clutch
coming in clutch the
astronaut figurine we thought it was a
worthless
item
oh and they can destroy our barriers
i'm just like spamming dude
oh my gosh
there's more there's more there's still
more
uh hello
wow yeah
dude right there are so many spots to
fall over here
oh my gosh
obelisk please thank you
no just no
dude i've got to make sure i start
hitting that reload
okay i just need to count the shots one
two three four five six
but if you wait a little bit
enhanced melee attack level three give
me that health
thank you thank you
oh my goodness all right we got
this is nuts absolutely
bonkers right now guys
okay it looks like there's something
below but we gotta get back over here
okay that's gonna take me straight down
onto you
proximity translocator all right let's
see where
it takes me takes me back up oh it's
gonna take me all the way up okay good
that spot that i was like hey how do i
get over there
oh i think we can reach this now
what do we have here instantly reach
adrenaline max
okay i really think i want that right
now
yeah dude we were we're very lucky 100
no arguments for me on that one i had no
idea what the doll
does oh great here we go again dude
like everywhere we go now it's just like
every room we go in
that does not do a lot of damage
we're not on lockdown so we could
actually leave this area
oh where did he go no he went through
the door
he freaking went through the door
oh my gosh there were still more enemies
in here i'm almost positive
oh there's health but it's like it's
it's really far away
it's really far away you see it like
way up there
i knew it man i knew it i told you
now it actually does really well on
those guys
this is one shot him
yeah we still got the music
let me in here
another ether okay we're finding a lot
more ether in this area
like i'd only had three all night and
then we found three here in the past
like 15 20 minutes or so
yep i saw you lurking
saw you lurking about yeah i was i was
ready for it that time
i was ready for it
oh
i'm not going to use that
it needs a large amount of omelets
needs a large amount of omelets
you know what i can take one
didn't even do it because remember i had
that upgrade that had the chance
now that one it didn't work that's fine
that is totally fine because i was only
going to get one but because that
upgrade it didn't affect me on the first
one
all right i need to get to one of these
warp points because i'd love to go back
to that area where i can buy
and upgrade some things
all right let's take a look at the
overall map here dude we have not come
across one of those
in a while way back here
those little things look like kind of
like a little wi-fi symbol
there it is there it is
nice okay
all right let's catch our breath a bit
man
that was an intense section
hydrate here i should probably get up
and stretch a little bit too but
i'm gonna wrap it up here soon at least
i think i'm gonna wrap it up soon
all right so we need to find that area
where we could buy
what was it called
i don't know if it's labeled on the map
actually
you know what i want to say it was close
to that guy
remember the wolverine dude
which actually i think i have enough now
for the wolverine guy
okay that one's by the house
xenoglyph it might be the xenoglyph
and then we got the fabricator right
there let's go here
dude so many terms in this game that you
gotta
get familiar with wait what
oh that thing stays on your map
oh so i need two more ciphers to be able
to
here it is man here it is all right i'm
going to do this one right here
because this is the one that gives you
that increased max integrity
by 25 percent
see like this is where they really need
to have a save and quit option
because like i don't trust the the rest
anymore of the ps5 i just don't trust it
i want to be able to save my game
but apparently unless i reach a certain
point
i mean i have no idea i don't know when
it saves like uh
dude that is so much health we've got
now
so much health we just need to fill it
up
to the max now i don't think i could get
up there yet
right i don't think we were able to
because otherwise
i feel like i would have went through
that but yeah i think i don't know
though dude like those platforms right
there
i'm gonna go back this way though dude
we're getting further we're getting
further away from the objective this is
crazy this place is huge
when you first open the map you're like
oh i'm not that far from the objective
i'm not that far and then the further
into it you get oh wait i think i saw
some
obelits and we need to collect a lot of
them to get our
malignancy to go away
how about you nope your eyes weren't
shining so no omelets
from you
fabricator powered with oblets
melee kills briefly increase speed by 25
percent
and protection by 25
that's a lot of omelets but let's do it
let's do it man
like we're getting pretty far into this
run i feel like
i feel like who knows it may not be that
far at all but
and i'm liking the melee ability more
and more so
to be able to like jump in melee and
then
get out even faster
it's gonna be helpful yeah we already
did the fabricator
i'm afraid to fall now in this game
yep yep i'm afraid to fall
like i thought that was i thought it was
solid ground dude
i thought wrong okay wait so where am i
supposed to go here
is this it like is this all that's here
we hit the fabricator right here
oh you can use that again
okay so wait what would the point of
this little area be
right here if you can't
get anywhere
yeah like that doesn't look like an area
you can jump on to me
it did it first it definitely did it
first but it does not now
all right well i mean i guess that's it
unless you can go can you get up there
no how about up here anything anything
anything there
hey this whole time by the way we've
been searching for the exact same thing
the exact same thing the anathema
key or whatever it's called
all right so wait where do we go then
guys
where do we go we did this whole area
over here that door
right there that's the door we need to
get to
all right so let's continue going back
i'm gonna use this translocator and
which one is going to put me the closest
definitely not you uh
actually this one right here i believe
this one right here should put me the
closest
and still not that close really
all right so we need to go oh yeah this
is where we just came earlier
all right we need to turn and
immediately go through
this door here
all the weapons do stay in the location
that's kind of cool i guess so if you
like change your mind now
how do i i wonder how i open oh my
goodness
dude i gotta start looking for that
i gotta start looking for that
horizontal barrage
nope
i don't know it is ranked four let's see
think i might like that better than the
shotgun style blast
all right which way we need to go
this way to the left here
oh yeah this place this place man
yeah we already went over there
let's go let's go
completely missed with that but it's
okay
it's okay
dude the melee is sick
like actually ridiculous
i still hear growling
what
oh my gosh man
what is happening are the ones with the
circle over them again a gateway
dude what the heck is a gateway
gateway to what gateway to what
i just want to reach a save boy please
oh one of these things
what's going on
well clearly i've got to check out the
red door
oh more of those dudes man
xenoglyph
question mark great
your eyes are already back open come on
dude
hey what does it require
oh it just requires one key
and a theme of vault a xenotech gate
that is more heavily secured requires a
unique key to open
but it sounds like it's just the
standard key
man i wish i hadn't used them all how
about this you're a key in here
are you a key
i could cleanse that one with ether if i
wanted to what
now the good news is that we unlocked
this so we can immediately get back to
this place
as soon as we find a key
but right now i need to go back to this
one
i i'm gonna have to i like i have to go
to work tomorrow guys like
this i'm just gonna have to trust that
the
the rest mode will work
i really don't want to lose this
progress but i don't know what else to
do at this point
you know like hopefully a lot of the
stuff that i've gotten will
carry over yeah you're gonna drop me
aren't you i knew it
i knew it
so hey you're not gonna give me anything
in here
no parasite okay there's one
let's see what he is fills two slots
toward max integrity
affected with malignancy you know what
i'm doing it
i need to collect resin the next one is
critical
yeah can't do anymore can't do any more
because the next one is critical
but i have a lot of health now
i really have oh it's scrambling my map
not a good time for that
let's see if you can still kind of make
it out
yeah i need to turn around and go like
in this direction
yes another one of these
number nine dude we've gotten so many of
these unlocked now
but the problem is if we die like none
of that is gonna carry over
what the heck is going on
al now
what is happening dude oh he's getting
healed again
i'm dead
i'm just gonna try to run around and get
help
no
not that guy again no dude no
not right now man
oh my gosh get to that health
it's not much oh it's not even health
great it's just the resin
that stupid tree like guy still over
there too
i thought i killed this guy man
i really did think i already killed this
guy
maybe it's just another version you know
oh we got him we got him we got him we
got him we got him
come on reload reload dude
no man i are you serious i kill the big
guy
and then i die to him
i die to him after that
after that
dude
i can't believe that i can't believe it
i really can't believe that i can't
believe i killed a big guy and then died
of the little one
oh guys that's going to do it for me man
i really appreciate you all hanging out
um like i said i wish this game had a
save and quit
because i would have quit long ago and
you know then maybe i don't maybe
maybe when i'm a little more refreshed i
wouldn't have died right there
so that's why i'm honestly not too upset
that i died
but yeah we've got to figure out the
item to cross those long gaps
it's got to be there somewhere so we got
to find that and then i think we'll
i think we'll be able to traverse the
area a lot better
so thank you all so much for hanging out